aquí tenemos dos compuestos este y este
y ambos podrían ser llamados 12 dimetil
ciclohexano sin embargo el de aquí
arriba tiene dos grupos metilo que van
hacia arriba o están saliendo hacia
nosotros en el espacio por lo que los
dos grupos metilo deben de estar en el
mismo lado del anillo y a esto lo
llamamos cis en este otro tenemos un
grupo metilo con una cuña y un grupo
metilo con guiones por lo que ambos
grupos metilo están en lados opuestos
del anillo y a esto lo llamamos trans
primero nos vamos a fijar en el
compuesto 612 dimetil ciclohexano y
vamos a dibujar sus dos con formaciones
de silla y luego vamos a ver el
compuesto trans aquí tenemos la
conformación de silla en el carbono 1
hay un grupo metilo axial arriba y un
hidrógeno ecuatorial abajo los
hidrógenos son verdes para distinguirlos
mejor
en el carbono 2 hay un grupo metilo
ecuatorial arriba y luego hay un
hidrógeno axial abajo cuando esta
conformación si ya pasa por una
inversión del anillo si roto este
carbono hacia arriba y roto este carbono
hacia abajo lo giramos un poco para que
podamos ver la otra conformación de
silla y analizamos qué pasó con nuestros
grupos ahora en el carbono
1 hay un grupo metilo ecuatorial arriba
y un hidrógeno axial abajo en el carbono
el grupo metilo está axial arriba y el
hidrógeno está ecuatorial abajo
ahora vamos a dibujar nuestras con
formaciones de silla empezaremos con la
del lado izquierdo ya hemos visto cómo
dibujar con formaciones de silla en
vídeos anteriores comenzamos con dos
líneas paralelas un poco desfasadas aquí
tenemos una línea y la otra línea
después trazamos una línea punteada que
apenas toque la parte superior de la
línea de arriba y luego nuestra otra
línea punteada va a ir aquí y tocar la
punta inferior de la línea de abajo
después pensamos en otro conjunto de
líneas paralelas trazamos una línea
partiendo de la línea de arriba hasta
aquí y luego trazamos una paralela a la
línea de ahí y finalmente dibujamos
nuestra última serie de líneas paralelas
que van desde este punto hasta aquí y
luego desde este punto hasta aquí a este
carbono le asignamos el número uno
comenzamos con un enlace axial arriba en
el carbono 1
y luego el carbono 2 sería axial abajo
ya que vamos alternando voy a detenerme
ahí no voy a dibujar el resto de los
hidrógenos solo para ahorrar tiempo si
regresamos al carbono 1 colocamos el
otro enlace ecuatorial abajo y luego en
el carbono 2 sería ecuatorial arriba
echemos un vistazo a nuestra imagen aquí
arriba podemos ver que nuestro grupo
metilo se encuentra axial arriba en el
carbono 1 así que ponemos un ch 3 axial
arriba y tenemos un hidrógeno ecuatorial
abajo en el carbono 1 en el carbono 2
nuestro grupo metilo está ecuatorial
arriba y luego tenemos un hidrógeno que
está axial abajo así que este es el
compuesto si estos dos grupos metilo
están en el mismo lado ambos están hacia
arriba en relación con el plano del
anillo sabemos que esta conformación de
silla está en equilibrio con la otra
conformación de silla así que ahora
vamos a dibujar una del lado derecho
empezamos con nuestras dos líneas
paralelas que están un poco desfasada
aquí está una de las líneas y aquí está
la otra
ahora trazamos nuestras líneas punteadas
ínter secando la parte superior de esta
línea e ínter secando la parte inferior
de esta línea después pensamos en
nuestro otro conjunto de líneas
paralelas aquí está una y aquí está la
otra y finalmente el último conjunto de
líneas paralelas que van de aquí hacia
acá y luego de aquí a este lado ahora
podemos ver que este es el carbono 1
aquí está el carbono 1 después de que
ocurrió la inversión del anillo y ahora
empezamos con un enlace axial abajo en
el carbono 1 así que voy a dibujar axial
abajo en el carbono 1 al carbono 2 ahora
le toca axial arriba vamos a colocar
nuestros grupos metilo y para ello
tenemos que dibujar los otros enlaces
este sería hacia arriba y luego hacia
abajo así que en el carbono 1 podemos
ver que nuestro grupo metilo se
encuentra ecuatorial
por lo que colocamos nuestro ch3 aquí y
nuestro hidrógeno está axial abajo luego
en el carbono 2 nuestro grupo metilo se
encuentra axial arriba
y nuestro hidrógeno está ecuatorial
abajo
así que cuando esté compuesto paso por
una inversión del anillo sabemos que
este es el carbono 1 donde nuestro grupo
metilo está en posición axial arriba y
de este lado
este es el carbono 1 nuestro grupo
metilo sigue estando arriba con respecto
al plano del anillo pero ahora es
ecuatorial esto es lo que sucede cuando
hacemos una inversión del anillo y luego
en el carbono 2 teníamos un grupo metilo
que estaba ecuatorial arriba y ahora
nuestro grupo metilo está axial arriba
así que para las dos con formaciones de
silla los grupos metilo están en el
mismo lado y es por eso que lo llamamos
cis en cuanto a cuál es la conformación
más estable para ambas con formaciones
tenemos un grupo metilo axial y un grupo
metilo ecuatorial por lo que son
equivalentes son iguales en términos de
energía
ahora veamos el compuesto trans 1/2
dimetil ciclohexano aquí tenemos a trans
1/2 dimetil ciclohexano en el carbono 1
tenemos un grupo metilo axial arriba y
un hidrógeno ecuatorial abajo en el
carbono 2 hay un hidrógeno ecuatorial
arriba y un grupo metilo axial abajo si
ocurra una inversión del anillo si subo
este carbono y jalo este carbono hacia
abajo y lo giro para que se pueda ver
nuestra otra conformación de silla ahora
vamos a analizar lo que pasó con
nuestros grupos metilo en el carbono 1
nuestro grupo metilo está ecuatorial
arriba y en el carbono 2 nuestro grupo
metilo está ecuatorial abajo
ahora vamos a dibujar las conformaciones
de silla para el compuesto trans los
compuestos 6 y trans son isómeros el uno
del otro son moléculas diferentes así
que vamos a dibujar esta conformación de
silla de la izquierda y empezamos con
nuestras líneas paralelas que están un
poco desplazadas aquí está una línea y
aquí está la otra a continuación
trazamos nuestras líneas punteadas una
intersecta la parte superior de esta
línea y la otra intersec a la parte
inferior de esta línea y luego dibujamos
una línea de aquí acá y otra línea
paralela a esa y colocamos el último
conjunto de líneas paralelas
este es nuestro esqueleto de carbono en
el carbono 1 empezamos axial arriba y
luego en el carbono 2 es axial abajo y
aquí tenemos abajo y luego arriba ya que
este es el carbono 1 vemos que nuestro
grupo metilo está axial arriba así que
colocamos nuestro grupo
y los axial arriba y después tenemos
nuestro hidrógeno ecuatorial abajo lo
dibujamos aquí en el carbono 2 el
hidrógeno está ecuatorial arriba y el
grupo metilo está axial abajo lo
dibujamos aquí
muy bien se puede ver que esos dos
grupos metilo están en lados opuestos
del anillo así que uno va hacia arriba
este está hacia arriba y este otro va
hacia abajo así que son trans uno
respecto al otro esta conformación de
silla está en equilibrio con nuestra
otra conformación dibujemos la de la
derecha
empezamos con nuestras líneas paralelas
dos pasadas
después dibujamos nuestras líneas
punteadas aquí y luego dibujamos nuestro
siguiente conjunto de líneas paralelas
de aquí para acá y de aquí para acá y
conectamos estos puntos muy bien este es
el carbono 1 y empezamos axial abajo en
este carbono el carbono 2 sería axial
arriba y luego vamos a poner los otros
enlaces aquí así muy bien aquí tenemos
al carbono 1 y vemos que nuestro grupo
metilo está ecuatorial arriba así que
ahora el grupo metilo del carbono 1 está
aquí y tenemos un hidrógeno que va hacia
abajo en el carbono 1
en el carbono 2 nuestro hidrógeno está
axial arriba
y nuestro grupo metilo está ecuatorial
abajo así que aquí está nuestro ch3 a
veces es difícil entender dónde van
estos enlaces ecuatoriales y un buen
consejo para ello es mirar a los axiales
por ejemplo nos fijamos en este enlace
de aquí y pensamos está arriba o hacia
abajo en relación al plano del anillo es
bastante difícil de ver pero este
claramente está hacia arriba así que eso
significa que este debe de estar abajo
así que aquí tienen este pequeño truco
muy bien vamos a ver a los dos grupos y
veamos lo que sucedió en nuestra
inversión del anillo empecemos con el
carbono 1 este es el carbono 1 con
nuestro grupo metilo que está axial
arriba después de la inversión del
anillo este grupo metilo quedó arriba
con respecto al plano del anillo pero
ahora es ecuatorial
este es el mismo grupo metilo en el
carbono todos nuestro grupo metilo está
axial abajo y de este lado está
ecuatorial abajo así que para ambas con
formaciones de silla los grupos metilo
están en lados opuestos del anillo si
analizamos estas dos con formaciones de
silla en términos de estabilidad para
esta de la izquierda tenemos dos
sustituyen test axiales esta no es tan
estable como la de la derecha la de la
derecha tiene nuestros 2 relativamente
voluminosos grupos metilo ecuatoriales y
sabemos que es el mejor lugar para ellos
eso disminuye el impedimento estético
así que la de la derecha es la
conformación más estable
por último vamos a hacer un problema
nuestro objetivo es dibujar la
conformación más estable detrás un
hotel-boutique 3 metil ciclohexano
sabemos que la conformación más estable
va a ser una conformación silla así que
vamos a empezar por dibujar una silla
tenemos una línea paralela y la otra
línea paralela que están un poco
desplazadas después trazamos unas líneas
punteadas que nos sirven de guías para
ayudarnos con el dibujo después nuestro
otro conjunto de líneas paralelas que
van de este punto a este punto y
trazamos una línea paralela a esa
después nuestro otro conjunto de líneas
paralelas va de este punto a este punto
y trazamos una línea paralela a esa muy
bien es trans lo que significa que
nuestros dos grupos están en lados
opuestos de nuestro anillo cuáles son
los dos grupos tenemos un grupo ter
butilo en el carbono 1 y tenemos un
grupo metilo en el carbono 3 así que
sabemos que este es el carbono 1 voy a
empezar con axial arriba este es axial
arriba y luego alternamos así que en el
carbono 2 debe de estar axial abajo
en el carbono 3 debe de ser axial arriba
y volvamos y coloquemos los ecuatoriales
así que en el carbono uno debe de estar
abajo en el carbono 2 debe de estar
hacia arriba y en el carbono 3 debe de
estar abajo
ahora vamos a dibujar nuestro grupo
debut y lo en el carbono 1 ahora tenemos
dos opciones donde ponemos nuestro grupo
de butilo lo ponemos axial o lo ponemos
ecuatorial sabemos que este es un grupo
muy voluminoso y a los grupos muy
voluminosos los colocamos ecuatoriales
así que tenemos una sola opción en el
carbono 1 debemos de poner el grupo
textil aquí debemos poner el grupo de
útil abajo en el carbono 1 por lo que
éste está abajo
y puesto que este compuesto es trans eso
significa que debemos poner el grupo
metilo hacia arriba en el carbono 3 así
que vamos al carbono 3 aquí está el
carbono 3 tenemos una sola opción
debemos colocar axial al grupo metilo
este es el único enlace que va hacia
arriba aquí está nuestro ch3
ahora vamos a borrar estos otros enlaces
solo para que esto se vea un poco más
bonito así que voy a borrar esto y esto
de aquí también se pueden dibujar todos
los hidrógenos podríamos dejar todo esto
de aquí pero prefiero eliminar esto un
poco voy a quitar nuestras líneas
punteadas para que podamos ver nuestra
conformación esta es la conformación más
estable detrás un hotel-boutique 3 metil
ciclohexano